>> Greg: TODAY IS TAKE YOUR
CHILD TO WORK DAY, EMPHASIS ON
YOUR.
GET THAT WRONG AND IT COULD BE
TAKE YOURSELF TO JAIL DAY.
A HALF OF ME HATES THIS DAY.
I DON'T LIKE SHARING THE
ELEVATOR WITH PEOPLE WERE
ONE-TENTH MY AGE AND 100% MY
HEIGHT.
PLUS IT MEANS DANA HAS TO WATCH
HER LANGUAGE IN THE HALLS AND WE
ALL KNOW HOW FILTHY SHE IS.
IT'S HARD TO FIRE SOMEONE WHO IS
THEIR KID WITH THEM.
HOW DO YOU DO THAT?
TELL THE PARENT TO WAIT OUTSIDE
AND TELL YOUR KID -- THE KID
YOUR DAD IS FIRED.
TAKE YOUR CHILD TO WORK DAY HAS
BECOME THE DAY YOU CAN'T SWEAR
OR FIRE ANYONE.
PEOPLE LIKE DANA WHO ENJOYS
SWEARING AND MAKING PEOPLE CRY.
I DON'T HAVE KIDS SO TODAY IS NO
DIFFERENT THAN YESTERDAY EXCEPT
WITH MORE SCREAMING WHICH SCARES
THE KIDS WHEN I DO IT.
THE OTHER HALF OF ME EMBRACES
THIS DAY.
IT'S GOOD THAT YOUR KIDS SEE
WHAT PEOPLE DO FOR A LIVING.
THEY NEED TO LEARN THAT MONEY
ISN'T SOMETHING THAT
MYSTERIOUSLY REGENERATES IN THE
WALLET.
MOM AND DAD HAVE TO WORK TO PAY
FOR YOUR CLOTHES, YOUR TOYS,
YOUR WORTHLESS POLITICALLY
CORRECT OVERPRICED EDUCATION.
WORK IS OFTEN THE THING YOU KNOW
LEAST ABOUT YOUR PARENTS.
I REMEMBER MY DAD TAKING ME TO
WORK, AND IT WAS THRILLING.
I DROVE THE GETAWAY CAR.
THAT'S WHERE I LEARNED ABOUT THE
MAGICAL MONEY IN THE WALLET.
IT'S GREAT TO SEE ANOTHER PLACE
WHERE YOUR PARENTS OR SOMEBODY
ELSE OR NOT IN A BATHROOM.
THEY HAD A ROLE OUTSIDE YOUR
WORLD.
YOUR PARENTS AREN'T JUST PARENTS
BUT HUMAN BEINGS HATED BY OTHER
HUMAN BEINGS.
ENJOY THE DAY BUT IF YOUR CAN
TOUCH AS ANYTHING ON DESK,
YOU'RE DEAD.
THEY MADE EARTH DAY EARTH WEEK.
TODAY IS TAKE YOUR CHILD TO WORK
SO HAVE COMBINED IT.
I TAKE MY PLANT TO WORK.
>> Dana: DID YOU CARRY IT ALL
DAY?
>> Greg: THAT'S TYLER.
IT >> Jesse: LOOKS DRY, LET ME
WATER IT.
>> Dana: MILES, THE
4-MONTH-OLD SON OF ONE OF OUR
PRODUCERS.
I SAW A COUPLE OF OTHER KIDS.
>> Greg: A 4-MONTH-OLD?
>> Dana: HE'S NEVER COME TO
VISIT US.
>> Greg: THE BABY IS NOT GOING
TO LEARN ANYTHING.
>> Dana: THEY ARE STARTING
EARLY.
>> Jesse: THE BABY ON YOUR
DESK.
>> Dana: BRINGING KIDS TO WORK
ONE DAY A YEAR IS A GOOD THING.
>> Greg: I DISAGREE.
I THINK, JUAN, AND SHOULD NOT BE
AN ORCHESTRATED THING.
BUT YOUR KID WHENEVER YOU WANT.
IT'S MORE EXCITING.
>> Dana: YOU THINK THAT WOULD
BE BETTER THAN ONE DAY?
>> Greg: I WAS A CHILD BEFORE
THIS FAKE HOLIDAY.
MY DAD WAS AN ACCOUNTANT.
IT WAS THRILLING TO ME.
CALCULATOR.
1970.
>> Juan: THAT THING I REMEMBER
ABOUT THIS, I TOOK MY DAUGHTER.
SHE WAS AT MY DESK AT
"THE WASHINGTON POST."
SHE KEPT THAT PICTURE FOREVER.
WOW.
IT WAS A BIG DEAL TO HER.
SEE WHERE YOUR DAD WORKS.
>> Dana: YOU ARE GONE ALL THE
TIME.
WHERE IS HE?
>> Greg: THIS IS WHERE DAD
GOES TO PAY FOR THAT FOOD.
>> Juan: I WISH THEY MADE THAT
CONNECTION.
I'M NOT SURE.
>> Jesse: I SAW MY DAUGHTER
TODAY AND SHE ASKED ME IF I HAD
MORE THAN $1,000 IN MY BANK
ACCOUNT.
[LAUGHTER]
SHE THINKS IT'S A LOT OF MONEY.
I SAID YES, I DO.
SHE WAS REALLY IMPRESSED.
IT MADE ME FEEL GREAT.
>> Dana: WHAT DID SHE WANT TO
BUY?
>> Jesse: WILL FIND OUT LATER.
I DIDN'T SEE ANY KIDS AT WORK
TODAY BECAUSE I GOT HERE AT 4:3
4:30.
>> Dana: SO YOU DIDN'T REALLY
WORK TODAY?
>> Jesse: I WAS WITH THE KIDS
ALL DAY!
>> Dana: CAN I GET THAT DEAL?
>> Greg: THEY ARE GOING TO
PLAY THIS BACK.
COMES IN AT 4:30.
>> Jesse: I LISTENED TO RUSH
LIMBAUGH.
>> Greg: EMILY, WHAT ARE YOUR
THOUGHTS?
YOU ARE YOUNG ENOUGH THAT YOU
PROBABLY WANT TO TAKE YOUR CHILD
TO WORK DAY.
>> Jesse: DID SOMEONE TAKE YOU
TO WORK TODAY?
>> Emily: I AM OLDER THAN YOU
ARE.
MY MOM WAS A LIBRARIAN.
>> Greg: IT'S LIKE QUINCY
MEETS --
>> Emily: MY LUNCH BAG WAS A
SPECIMEN BAG.
LATER I REALIZE HOW ODD IT WAS.
FOR ORGANS AND STUFF.
IT KEPT MY FOOD COLD.
MY POINT IS WE SHOULD HAVE A
BRING YOUR DOG TO WORK DAY.
>> Dana: THEY DO HAVE ABOUT
SOME WORKPLACES.
>> Jesse: I FORGET IS THIS
FRIDAY.
>> Emily: AT FOX?
>> Jesse: BRING YOUR DOG TO
WORK DAY.
ONE IS THAT?
SOMEONE JUST TOLD ME.
>> Dana: BEING RAISED AS A
SERVICE DOG.
IT'S NOT LIKE BRINGING JASPER TO
WORK.
>> Emily: IF WE ALL DID IT AT
ONCE IT WOULD BE GREAT.
>> Greg: WHAT HAPPENS TO THE
ROBOTS?
WHAT WILL THEY BRING TO WORK?
A TOASTER?
LITTLE ROBOTS.
A TINY CIRCUIT.
>> Juan: THE BAG, I HOPE YOU
DIDN'T GET A LIVER SANDWICH.
>> Greg: YOU HAVE TO ASK
YOURSELF IF YOUR KID CAN'T COME
TO YOUR PLACE OF WORK.
>> Jesse: CERTAIN PLACES CAN'T